jean françois copé le président de l'ump
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
soit aussi d'honorer ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse et dailymotion avec nous
tout à l'heure des bras claude de la fp
et perrine tarneaud de public siona pour
aborder bien sûr la situation politique
celle du gouvernement celle de
l'opposition celle du gouvernement avec
le report de la loi famille
vous aviez demandé la démission de
michel sapin après la progression du
chômage est ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui la démission de la ministre
de la famille dominique bertinotti même
si elle peut se sentir renforcés lieu
par la colère et les propositions à
venir des députés socialistes
ces deux sujets différents pour ce qui
concerne michel sapin vous savez il ya
quand même une réalité
le président de la république s'est
engagé personnellement a mis sa
crédibilité dans la balance auprès des
français sur l'idée de dire aux baissera
le chômage c'est promis on a la solution
miracle les contrats aidés c'est à dire
des contrats de public avec de l'argent
public le pire étant d'ailleurs dans le
même temps ils ont baissé les contrats
pour l'apprentissage qui est dans
l'entreprise mans c'est un échec total
j'ai fait observer que dans n'importe
quel pays anglo saxons comme c'est à ce
point l'engagement personnel du même nom
mais c'est une telle pantomime ce
gouvernement c'est tellement dramatique
de voir les échecs successifs que ce
soit monsieur valls en matière de
sécurité que ce soit monsieur le sapin
matière de chômage
que ce soit monsieur moscovici le
ministre du budget en matière de
réduction du déficit budgétaire
mais pouvoir en décompte le fiasco en
vingt mois le socialiste qui était censé
sauver la france de la politique
paraît-il terrible qui était menée par
la majorité ump quand on voit
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est advenu
c'est une
débandade terrible à laquelle on est
madame bertinat tient aujourd'hui le
véritable sujet c'est quelle vivre des
élections municipales qui sont en train
de se transformer en un véritable vote
sanction et moi je le dis une nouvelle
fois votre antenne j'appelle les
français à tirer les conséquences de ce
qu'il voit et d'exprimer leur colère à
travers ce que j'appelle vote utile
c'est à dire un vote dès le premier tour
pour les candidats de l'ump c'est la
seule manière d'ailleurs deux marqué un
désaveu très nettes contre françois
hollande s'il veut espérer également à
votre sanction par exemple d'une partie
de la gauche qui a déçu par l'abandon de
certaines réformes de société
moi je me mets à la place d'un électeur
de gauche
il doit être profondément désabusé car
voilà un président de la république qui
leur a promis le rêve je voulais
réenchanter le rêve et on voit
aujourd'hui une situation économique et
sociale terrible
l'explosion du du chômage lié à
l'explosion des impôts qui conduit
aujourd'hui l'aca développement terrible
de la précarité dans notre pays c'est un
d'ailleurs michel grossiord je voudrais
le dire sur notre antenne c'est un
non-dit terrible que de voir aujourd'hui
dans notre pays des millions de français
qui se trouvent aujourd'hui du fait des
hausses massives d'impôts dans des
situations véritable de précarité et je
pense aux classes moyennes
commerçants artisans patrons de pme
salariés salariés modestes mais bien sûr
vous n'imaginez pas le nombre de mes
administrés à ma permanence que je tiens
en tant que maire amo qui viennent me
dire on n'y arrive plus alors on va
revenir sur la famille mais à propos des
impôts justement il y a des idées dans
l'air notamment qui alimente la
réflexion de certains députés
socialistes pour une moindre
déductibilité de la cg que pensez vous
de cette proposition
un nouveau hold up sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français vous vous rendez
compte
là c est juste un impôt s'est payée par
tous les français
et voilà que la nouvelle idée folle du
rapporteur général du budget qui n'en
est pas à son coup d'essai qui fait
preuve d'ailleurs d'une une approche
idéologique terrible il dit agir et
réfléchir au nom de la progressivité de
l'impôt oui oui oui tu es toujours des
bonnes des bons arguments c'est comme ça
qu'il expliquait que la taxe à 75% pour
les plus fortunés qui
fait hurler le monde entier qui
d'ailleurs n'investit plus en france la
taxe à 75% c'était une punition une
sanction avec les 10 les plus riches
parce que c'était une faute d'être riche
en france depuis que les socialistes
sont au pouvoir
alors là la nouvelle folie c'est de dire
aux français vous avez payé de l'impôt
sur le cng et bien maintenant on va vous
faire payer de l'impôt sur le revenu sur
l'impôt que vous avez payé
c'est extrêmement grave 7 on arrive à un
niveau de spoliation du pouvoir d'achat
des français qui est absolument inouïe
inouïe et or le plus incroyable c'est
que tout cela se fait après que le
président de la république ait fait une
conférence de presse il ya maintenant
trois semaines pour dire j'arrête tout
cela désormais y aura plus de hausses
d'impôts il y aura plus de hausse des
prélèvements en tous les cas dublin de
taux d'imposition général où elle a
écouté vous fait un bel effort
ceux-ci l'indéfendable attendait mais
moi j'ai compris que les trop d'impôts
et certains j'ai compris je vais payer
plus d'impôts mais globalement la note
ah bah écoutez ce nantais par l'état
c'est là pas de chance parce que ça
tombe toujours sur les classes moyennes
c'est à dire ceux qui n'ont jamais droit
à rien et qui paye pour tout le monde
savait je crois qu'il faut quand même
bien voir qu'on est arrivé là un niveau
de denis payre fiscalité qui étrangle le
pays
moi je le vois je sais je parcours la
france dans tous les sens j'étais hier
on n'aura mis qu'une à lens j'ai parlé
avec beaucoup de deux jeux de françaises
et de français je vais croiser dans le
train de quasiment fait une réunion dans
le train tellement les gens venaient me
dire on n'en peut plus on est étranglé
par les impôts des socialistes
concernant la réforme sur la suspension
alors monsieur quand pierre vouloir
fiscalisés la csg donnera lieu de la
part de l'ump à une dénonciation
massives et encore une fois je dis aux
français les élections municipales
première fois qu'ils vont pouvoir voter
depuis les présidentielles de 2012 ça
doit être l'occasion d'un non massif et
donc concernant la réforme sur la
famille donc finalement cette réforme
elle reviendra avant la fin du
quinquennat après les municipales
entendent claude bartolone ça y est je
crois que claude bartolone a tout de
suite le fait tomber le masque en
réalité il ya une fracture profonde au
sein de cette majorité
françois hollande est paniqué il a
laissé libre cours à toutes les folies
lui même d'ailleurs il y avait participé
je rappelle que sur la pma parce que
personne ne le dit donc il est bien
tentant de retrouver les déclarations
des uns et des jouets laissé entendre un
magazine têtu effet à donner ses
propositions précédentes faut qu'il faut
qu'on m'explique là qu'est ce que c'est
alors donc que ce soit c'est dans les
professions présidentielle mais que ça
veut dire que quand on fait une
interview à têtu c'est juste pour aller
chercher des électeurs
donc il dit le 29 avril 2012 on est donc
quelques jours avant le deuxième tour de
la présidentielle françois hollande à la
question êtes vous favorable à
l'ouverture de la pma aux couples de
lesbiennes
réponse de françois hollande oui il dit
mais oui je les dis ce qui prouve qu'ils
aient donc une répétition ce qu'il
allait justement il est animé par une
volonté d'apaiser le climat
c'est un joli mot pour dire simplement
qu'en réalité les socialistes sont en
train de se heurter à la colère de ces
socialistes sont en train de se heurter
à colère des français
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui le pays réel celui qui vit
de lille à l'extérieur du périphérique
parisien est aujourd'hui en train de
dire à françois hollande il n'ya qu'une
seule chose dont vous devriez vous
occuper c'est la baisse du chômage
la compétitivité et la sécurité des
français or qu'est ce que nous voyons
nous voyons un gouvernement qui tous les
jours sans compter les députés de la
majorité tous les jours viennent
s'immiscer dans la vie privée des
français
je voudrais vous dire michel conscient
la chose suivante la grande leçon qu'on
doit tirer de tout ce qui est en train
de se passer
la grande leçon c'est qu'en réalité les
français ne supportent pas que l'on
vienne en permanence depuis le
gouvernement s'immiscer dans leur vie
privée
je souhaite moi j'aspire à une société
plus de région de sofia une société du
libre choix
laissons les françaises et les français
choisir dans le cadre des lois
existantes leur mode de vie plutôt que
de venir s'occuper de leur vie conjugale
de venir s'occuper et quand même on
pourrait évoquer de l'avec la théorie du
genre de l'éducation des enfants
pourquoi croyez vous que tant de
français soit inquiet aujourd'hui le
gouvernement multiplie dénégations sur
la théorie du genre
sauf que les documents sont là je les ai
évoqué produits mais c'est de l'égalité
c'est un coup spécialisation des élèves
à l'égaler lorsque vous voyez une
convention
ariel signée par cinq ministres cinq
ministres en 2013 dans lequel il est
écrit les savoirs scientifiques issus
des recherches sur le genre doivent
nourrir les politiques publiques
c'est écrit en toutes lettres et ses co
signé par monsieur sapin monsieur
peillon madame vallaud belkacem madame
fioraso laurent tu aimes la défense
mais pour vous en avait parlé fin
seulement nous sommes écoutés non
seulement magie très du tout mais c'est
la réalité
mettez vous à la place des parents je
pas si vous êtes père de famille mais
moi je peux vous dire que je ne cesse de
voir autour de moi et et en tant que
père de famille je suis tout aussi
sensibilisés à la question un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui disent
mais qu'est ce que le gouvernement vient
s'occuper de faire des cours sur la
théorie du genre
alors que on a un recul de 9 à une
aggravation l'illettrisme à l'entrée en
6ème que l'apprentissage est piétinée et
que nous avons les résultats que sur la
famille jean françois copé les députés
sont révoltés ils veulent revenir
effectivement avec leurs propositions
déclinées gauche et député socialiste
mais vous dites ils veulent s'immiscer
dans la vie mieux intime mais il s'agit
de pacifier le divorce
ils sont les hôtes y est dit étonné
qu'il s'agit par exemple il s'agit par
ce qu'ils veulent c'est à dire parce que
vous vous pensez qu en substituant un
jeu le juge actuel des affaires
familiales de leur substituer à greffier
ça va pacifier le divorce c'est la
volonté affichée mais donc la vraie
bombe
chaque pointe était l'un des combats de
nadine morano par ips ont reçu apprenons
chaque point celui qui consiste à
substituer à griffier au juge des
affaires familiales pour venir par un
simple coup de tampon homologuer une
convention de divorce c'est simplement
la pire manière de procéder
je suis désolé de dire que la procédure
de divorce
et c'est l'avocat qui parle la procédure
de divorce c'est un acte majeur alors
prenons un autre exemple
mais non parce que celui là vous avez
raison de le prendre il fait partie de
ces gens nés de ses lubies de la
chancellerie pour nous dire on va on va
banaliser par exemple un statut du beau
parent jeu c'est à un combat par exemple
de la ministre nadine
nous donne un statut aller à ces
personnes qui s'occupent des enfants
dans les familles recomposées je n'ai
pas de problème avec l'idée d'évoquer un
statut protecteur pour les beaux parents
mais le problème c'est que dans la loi
en question on se moque des français et
on est en l'occurrence on se moque des
députés de l'opposition
on nous dit avec la bouche en coeur il y
aura rien sur la pma et la gpa sauf que
dans la même semaine
madame fioraso encore ministre nous a
expliqué qu' il pourrait tirer des
amendements alors après on nous dit oui
mais monsieur valls nous a dit que
monsieur max ministre de l'intérieur
vous voyez le rapport
le djia nommé tout ce qui concerne la
pma ne sera pas acceptée ah bon mais
monsieur leroux deux heures après a dit
assis et si ça n'est pas sous la forme
d'amendements ce sera une proposition de
loi et monsieur bartolone vient de
couper court aux déclarations de
monsieur ayrault à la demande de
monsieur alain puisque monsieur ayrault
nous dit c'est reporté sine aidiez et
monsieur bartolone jean et d'un honneur
s'est remis au lendemain des municipales
monsieur gros sûr il ya un plan caché et
je crois qu'il est grand temps que celle
qu'elle entendrait ce plan caché est le
suivant le gouvernement a décidé pour
essayer de limiter les dégâts aux
élections municipales de reporter tous
les textes qui viendraient fâcher les
français pour leur imposer après je
prends dans l'ordre la réforme pénale de
madame taubira un texte
extraordinairement laxiste pour les
délinquants
le droit de vote pour les étrangers dont
monsieur hollande parle de manière
récurrente ce qui lui permet d'ailleurs
de jouer avec le front national
l'artiste la loi sur la famille qui
vient exactement dans la foulée dont
monsieur bertin lundi dès le lendemain
des municipales on le remet sur la table
voilà ce qu'il en est alors si vous
ajoutez à tout cela le plan fiscal qui
est en train de se mettre en place
beaucoup plus vite que le soi disant
pacte de responsabilité qui s'étiole
tous les jours le plan fiscal dans
lequel nous allons retrouver la
fiscalisation de la csg qui vient
s'ajouter à toute la mise en cause de la
politique fiscale sur le plan familial
premier rabot du quotient familial à
l'été 2012
deuxième rabot du quotient familial pour
la loi de finances 2014
fiscalisation des majorations de pension
pour les retraités parents de trois
enfants et plus pour financer les
retraites réduction de fête du congé
parental pour la plupart des parents
décidés dans la loi égalité mais
changement pour douala encore notamment
les pères
oui vous avez le quand même vu que quand
vous faites le total si jamais les pères
ne le prend pas il ya malheureusement
des pères qui ne peuvent pas le prendre
c'est perdre ses glorieux vous allez
rencontrer angela merkel
oui enfin le 11 février absolument c'est
pas pour prendre une leçon d'union
nationale parce que là bas ils arrivent
à s'entendre sur les grands enjeux du
moment un
conservateurs/sociaux-démocrates draoui
mais vous avez vu que là bas celui qui a
initié la modernisation du marché du
travail
c'est un socialiste c'était un des
c'était monsieur art qui avait été
sollicité par monsieur schröder premier
ministre social démocrate
nous en sommes très loin aujourd'hui
montebourg qui dit aujourd'hui même il
est temps de s'unir pour redresser le
pays et met en avant le crash
le pack de responsabilité qui a l'aval
quand même d'une partie vos amis à lui
une pénurie fans de moins en moins parce
que sans comprendre ce que des mois
j'avais alerté un je vais disputer une
boîte bien sûr qui peut être contre la
seule chose c'est qu'on va attendre de
voir parce qu'on est habitué avec
monsieur hollande à ce que les promesses
ne soient jamais suivies d'effet c'est
pas hélas la première fois donc qu'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il se passe
que monsieur hollande s'est moqué des
français en leur disant il ya trois
semaines j'ai compris je vais changer de
politique ne change rien du tout les 50
milliards de baisses de dépenses
publiques n'arriveront jamais on l'a
compris depuis déjà trois semaines pas
une seule annonce la seule annonce une
hausse de dépenses
ils veulent faire cinquante mille
contrats aidés supplémentaires la vérité
monsieur gros sûr c'est que ils ne
baisseront pas les dépenses ils vont
continuer d'augmenter les impôts ils ne
moderniseront pas le marché du travail
par contre ils sont capables de
mobiliser les français sur des sujets
qui objectivement ne sont vraiment pas
d'urgence qui qui touche à la société
française que c'est tout cela est
absolument dramatique je me mets à la
place de nos compatriotes qui se disent
mais comment at on pu se retrouver dans
cette situation d'avoir un gouvernement
socialiste qui a tous les pouvoirs et
qui à ce point les utilisent pour
déstructurer une société qui au
contraire besoin d'apaisement l on va
parler maintenant des propositions de
l'ump où il ya un autre sujet qui divise
vous n'êtes pas tous d'accord quand même
sur le virage pro entreprise de françois
hollande c'est le retour maintenant
évident de nicolas sarkozy on en parle
dans un instant avec deborah clos de
leur respect mais d'abord
le point donc sur ce retour annoncé par
l'intéressé lui-même de plus en plus
clairement
jérôme bonnard là où la mer est passé
elle revient l'ancien président n'est
pas avare de métaphores devant les
journalistes c'était jeudi dernier en
charente maritime
au fil de ses déplacements nicolas
sarkozy fait visiblement tout pour se
faire désirer une mise en scène parfaite
ça marche très bien avec les médias mais
ça marche derrière les médias ça marche
avec le public à qui on raconte
l'histoire du retour gagnant d'un homme
qui avait perdu et qui remonte sur le
ring et qui gagne en fait quand on y
réfléchit c'est le scénario de requis 2
même si la ressemblance n'est pas
évident au premier abord
en fait tout est dans la subtilité car
en envoyant ses cartes postales nicolas
sarkozy s'adresse aussi et surtout à ses
concurrents les ténors de l'ump
et là encore vive les comparaisons les
fans de harry potter apprécieront
peut-être m'est arrivé aussi de comparer
à voldemort c'est à dire que c'est celui
dont on ne prononce jamais le nom mais
auquel tout le monde pense à l'ump et
dont le le retour est forcément
inéluctable mais peut-on parler d'un
retour gagnant
nicolas sarkozy l'homme providentiel pas
question de laisser émerger une relève à
droite
pas question de primaires en 2016 60%
des sympathisants souhaitent son retour
et il peut compter sur les indétrônables
lieutenant et autres fidèles supporteurs
mais les fameuses cartes postales
n'atteignent visiblement pas tous les
destinataires
la méthode sarkozy a peut être aussi ses
limites gare aux phénomènes d'illusions
c'est à dire de vouloir faire une
tactique qui soit profondément contraire
à ce qui l'est c'est terre que nicolas
sarkozy ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
attend d'être réclamé dans son caractère
nicolas sarkozy c'est bonaparte ce n'est
pas pierre mendès france décidément les
comparaisons vont bon train
côté ump certains en rajoute même une
couche tout en laissant place à une
certaine ambiguïté le général de gaulle
n'a pas demandé de prix mais alors si
les revenus
voilà et il était le bienvenu quand jean
françois copé s'est présenté il a dit si
nicolas revient je serai à ses côtés
eh bien c'est dit qu elle revient moi
aussi je serai à ses côtés à porto ce
moment là on fait un syllogisme et nous
nous retrouvons au côté de jean françois
copé
aujourd'hui comme demain
voilà entre syllogisme donc à charron et
puis quand parise ont de nicolas sarkozy
avec la mer qui revient toujours bonsoir
des bons restos sont questions à jean
françois copé sur l'ump dont l'ump sur
sur rocchi 2 puisque c'était ce qu'on me
disait dans le sujet alors est ce que
nicolas sarkozy ait une espérance pour
la france comme nous l'a dit brice
hortefeux
la semaine dernière elle a dit sur les
ondes de rtl est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
retour de l'ancien chef de l'état je
peux pas vous répondre je n'en sais
strictement rien moi toute façon vous
savez quelle est ma position je les dis
nombreuses reprises simplement je veux
juste vous livrer une réflexion
supplémentaire je pense que aujourd'hui
ce qui compte ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
ça pour les français les français vivent
au quotidien une situation très durs
ceux qui ont voté pour françois hollande
sont aujourd'hui les fondre est désabusé
déçu ceux qui ont voté pour nicolas
sarkozy se disent vraiment quel gâchis
depuis 20 mois
et aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
étape nouvelle je pense que la france de
2014 n'est plus celle de 2012 mais
qu'elle n'est pas encore celle de 2017
ce qui compte au jour la notion
d'espérance est ce que nicolas sarkozy
incarne oui ou non une aspirine espère
en flandre je n'ai pas de doute un
instant bien sûr qu'il incarne une
espérance mais encore une fois
aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est qu'elle
projet qu'est ce que nous proposons aux
français et moi même a bien sûr encore
2010 elle se serait passé des choses je
me sens chez vous me sens pas ses 1000
mais en même temps on essaie quand même
d'organiser des primaires de bordé c'est
toujours ça c'est autre chose
les primaires c'est autre chose mais
encore une fois
comprenez moi ma mission n'est pas tout
à fait la même que celle des autres
notamment de mes aînés moi je suis dans
l'action il en est qui peuvent se
permettre ce coup ci
oui bien sur wii ou d'autres non mais
attendez
ma mission n'est pas la même il en est
parmi eux qui peuvent se permettre de ne
pas parler d'être silencieux de ne pas
être dans le combat quotidien
en revanche pour moi c'est interdit moi
je suis dans le combat quotidien ou
j'aime pas beaucoup cette explosion est
ce que je la trouve un peu péjoratif
c'est ce que je vais faire les élections
ce que je fais oui plusieurs semaines
vous répéter encore tout à l'heure les
municipales mais il faut voter ump aux
municipales ça très bien non mais non je
répète simplement mais voilà c'est une
citation merci donc effectivement vous
vous êtes là pour les mois de mars
prochain les résidents des européennes
et ensuite j'ai encore les sénatoriales
les cantonales et régionales
ce que je veux juste vous dire c'est que
ma mission elle est que ma famille
politique renoue avec la victoire
nous n'avons pas gagné d'élections
locales depuis 2000 à ce moment depuis
2001 une éternité et donc quelque part
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est que les
français sachent qu'ils un chef de
l'opposition qui est tous les jours au
combat au sens noble du terme et ont
départagés au nombre permanente de
nicolas sarkozy traduit un manque de
leadership à droite vous n'empêcherez
jamais
2 les envieux de grâce est mais tel
n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui ce qui
compte pour moi c'est que nous ayons une
ligne politique
alors c'est moi nous ayons des candidats
investis dans les milieux et des bas
comme un bon rapport entre vous mais sur
la ligne sur la ligne au bout je suis
pas d'accord j'ai des diplômes et son
ami sont passionnants et la ligne
politique elle a été acté il ya un grand
monde n'y a rien fait nous vend quand
même on a fait le conseil national
c'est-à-dire jeux wii fin janvier le
dressage en face à tant d 4 93% de vote
favorable de tous les cas c'est un
moment très important
au contraire ça a été adoptée à
l'unanimité à la fois par le mes amis de
l'équipe dirigeante et ensuite par 93%
des données personnelles comme françois
baroin alain juppé qui ont trouvé que
votre votre avis vous la tribu est trop
libérez vous l'avez évoqué nos talents
dans la première partie de cette
émission jean françois copé sur les
baisses d'impôts ce que vous annoncez
sur les économies budgétaires 130
milliards d'euros sur ces été adopté là
où siècle vous avez les occassions
d'emilie de réveiller lequel il ya enfin
la modernisation du marché du travail a
su mais concrètement par exemple ça veut
dire quoi vous pourriez par exemple
imaginer une modulation du smic voire la
suppression du smic oh non c'est pas ça
que j'ai pensé non on a pensé à bien
d'autres choses on a pensé par exemple à
l'idée de d'en finir avec les 35 heures
est de dire désormais c'est la
négociation par entreprise ou par
branches qui va faire le temps de
travail l'organisation dans l'entreprise
plutôt que ces espèces d' immense barnum
21 interprofessionnelle où on mélange le
secteur du btp le secteur du nucléaire
le numérique
l'hôtellerie etc bon donc typiquement
ont fini avec les 35 heures dans le
secteur privé mais aussi dans
l'administration
imaginez demain des fonctionnaires moins
nombreux mais mieux considérer mieux
payés repenser caisse quand on dit mais
c'est 230 milliards c'est 10 % de la
dépense publique aujourd'hui un ménage
une entreprise dans la difficulté est
bien le people lui arrivait de faire 10%
d'économies savons pas si le temps ne
fait jamais le faire on peut faire 130
milliards d'économies budgétaires ou
l'état l'elysée
mais qu'est ce que c'est baisser les
impôts en marmonnant des français c'est
ce que va vous avez forcément lu ce
qu'on a écrit vous êtes des gens
attentifs
qu'est ce qu'on a dit on a dit qu'on
fait 130 milliards de baisses de
dépenses publiques et que dans le c 130
milliards ont fait 65 milliards de
baisses d'impôts et 65 milliards de
baisse de la dette
bon il s'agit en vérité de faire ce que
tous les autres pays qui s'en sortent en
europe ont fait avant nous l'allemagne
l'espagne la grande bretagne c'est ce
travail là alors après vous dit tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord
écoutez d'abord mettait pas alain juppé
dans le lot des gens pas d'accord ils
étaient présents il a voté et il m'a
téléphoné pour me dire qu'il était tout
à fait en phase donc là dessus nous
arrêtons de le faire parler à sa place
pour le reste vous n'empêcherez car
plusieurs familles sont les européennes
il va falloir concilier des positions ça
c'est encore autre chose et je vais me
sentir dans cinq ans voire celle là on
parlait aussi longtemps non mais deborah
je suis dit pas de problème on va parler
aussi des européennes a juste pour finir
sur le projet économique
il peut y avoir ici ou là vous
n'empêcherez pas tel ou tel vous dire
qu'il est contre
c'est pas grave qu'une minorité pourquoi
est-ce qu'à gauche il tape tous dessus
c'est frais et printanier à droite
c'était absolument catastrophique on a
plutôt l'habitude que ça bah non ça
s'est passé comment la droite mais
l'ajustement
on a vraiment eu à une énigme limité
très forte pourquoi d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire c'est très simple qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent les français
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent quand on parle
avec eux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs douche
chaude radis vous dise quoi hein on veut
plus de liberté économique
on n'en peut plus des contrôles
l'inspection du travail des rigidités
des impôts et des charges plus de
liberté économique
2 les français nous disent on veut
rétablir l'autorité de l'état
ça tombe bien c'est dans notre projet et
3 on veut l'égalité des chances
l'égalité des droits et des devoirs
légalité des efforts pourquoi l'état
fait jamais défaut alors que nous on en
fait voilà le projet de l'ump c'est
êtes-vous taper dessus
les français dans le train quand vous
parlez à vos côtés pour tout vous dire
il peut arriver qu'il le dise
mais il est vrai que c'est une question
vous nous posez beaucoup plus souvent
que d'accord parce que vous vous êtes
énormément là dessus alors qu'en réalité
quand on fait l'inventaire des choses ça
va pas si mal que ça à l'ump
quand je vois ce que nous étions à la
fin 2012 désir dans cette période à la
fois de deuil après des élections
présidentielles nous avions perdu et de
crise interne à la suite de mon élection
bon entre-temps l'année 2013 je l' ai
consacré à rassembler et réconcilier
j'ai déjà refusé fait un choix un qui
consistait à dire pour y arriver je ne
réponds pas
aux injures aux insultes et aux
caricatures dont j'ai été l'objet
ça m'a pesé 1 parce qu'on en a dit les
horreurs sur moi et pourtant je me suis
dit il faut accepter la dessus de ne
rien dire pour rassembler les gens et
tourner la page et c'est grâce à ça
qu'on a eu un conseil national
les gens étaient rassemblés un peu
obsédé par les primaires mais est-ce que
les primaires finalement ça oui déjà un
il renvoie à leur terme première
question et deuxièmement est ce que
finalement c'est pas une machine à
réactiver la compétition interne en
permanence nos questions voilà de quoi
bon est ce que certains pour sa maison
votre écoute et moi quand c'est la
gauche qui fait les prix mais on dit que
c'est démocratique quand c'est la droite
qui fait des primaires on dit c'est la
machine à s'entretuer faudrait savoir
oui mais parce que c'est bonaparte et un
kit 2 et d'ailleurs ça veut dire quoi
alors je sais il ya soixante hommes et
102 de gens qui veulent un candidat il y
aura pas de primaires c'est la question
c'est la question
écoutez je vais vous dire ce soir en
tant que président de l'ump
vous avez mis sur les rails
effectivement les primaires est-ce qu'il
est rare jusqu'à senteurs bien sûr il ya
des statuts il erra jusqu'à fayard des
statues ses statuts ont été adoptés à
une écrasante majorité y pour défaire
une écrasante majorité des gamins d'à
côté c'est pas drôle r non mais c'est
une façon je vous pose mais pourquoi ils
le seraient pas c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche des des statuts qui ont été
adopté qui prévoit beaucoup de choses
donc une primaire donc moi je suis
aujourd'hui garonne ce statut comme le
sont d'ailleurs tous les toutes les
personnes physiques il est qui les ont
élaboré et soumis aux va pas passer par
cette primaire serait un risque pour le
mp2 division justement au premier tour
de la présidentielle avec le s écouter
si vous avez cinq candidats de l'ump
qu'on n'a pas départagé avant qu'ils se
retrouvent candidat à la présidentielle
au premier tour c'est un problème
nicolas sarkozy toile c'est encore une
fois les centristes à votre primeur sur
une petite question comme ça à long
terme oat et j'en sais rien je faillis
long j'imagine leur propre désignation
de candidats j'ai pas vraiment réfléchir
ça pulse et nous on a des centristes à
l'ump vous évoquiez jean pierre raffarin
marc philippe daubresse il ya que d'un
courant humaniste et centriste qui est
très important à l'ump mais tu vas juste
vous dire la chose suivante je vous en
ai déjà dit beaucoup sur les primaires
je peux pas vous en dire plus pour une
raison simple c'est que moi aujourd'hui
mon agenda numéro un
c'est l'année qui vient c'est des
municipales c'est les européennes c'est
les sénatoriales
c'est pour ça que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il en est qui peuvent se taire
parler une fois tous les 36 du mois
avoir une parole rare donc très oxygénée
c'est pas mon cas moi je suis amené de
personnes six t2 est nominé est en deuil
a pas besoin de mettre des noms il ya
des gens qui n'étant pas en
responsabilité immédiate n'ont pas
besoin de parler tous les jours dans la
place qui est la mienne comme mon ami
christian jacob à la présidence du
groupe à l'assemblée nationale
nous sommes au combat tous les jours
parce que parce que c'est notre rôle
c'est mission année enduré au plus fort
de la bataille pour la présidence avec
françois fillon s'en souvient
effectivement mais quand vous entendez
aujourd'hui henri guaino qui lui a été
traité de joueur de grosse caisse c'est
à dire que vous êtes un joueur de pipeau
vous encaissez encore la non monsieur
rien c'est pas grave alors une fois
mettons pas tout
s'il faut faire la liste de tous à face
à aucun sens c'est pas grave
bon ok on connaît son tempérament il
s'était il s'était mis voilà il
s'emporte souvent ici on pour jean luc
romero c'est bon mais chacun sont
tempérées mer et sam à vous m'avez
répondu sur les grilles fin janvier
jérôme est ce que vous écoutez peu
importe tout ça franchement ce n'est pas
du niveau si vous le permettez de notre
entretien qui je crois en gage d'abord
la préoccupation des français
qu'est ce que nous proposons face à la
politique de l'agglomération sur
l'europe justement on les veut pas que
sur le positionnement opposition il ya
un sondage tout nous ramène à henri
guaino dayori son âge qui est sorti il
ya deux ou trois semaines effectivement
on tout on était un peu dans un mouchoir
de poche
enfin pas du tout si on parle du même
jeu sur les intentions de vote oui c'est
ça pas du tout
c'est là où je pense qu'il est vraiment
important que puisque vous dans votre
métier vous êtes tellement attaché à
lire les sondages
vous les lisez une chose en commun ça
coûte et moi c'est une chose qui m'a
beaucoup frappé j'ai je fréquente
beaucoup vos confrères de la presse
internationale
ils sont eux-mêmes impressionnée elle
voir combien vos jugements sont d'abord
orientée par le sondage dire que vous
pouvez être un ministre nulle si vos
sondages sont très bons personne n'en
dira du mal al'inverse si jamais vos
sondages sont mauvais ou pouvez même
faire des choses juste une chose au
moins ils ont le correctement quelques
petits ce dernier sondage premièrement
le front national qu'à trois points
personnes l'écrit
deuxièmement nous sommes dans la marge
d'erreur autre front national et l'ump
écoutez je crois que c'est 23 pour l'un
22 pour l'autre bon et deuxième élément
vous dites un mouchoir de poche vous
avez vu ce mouchoir vous le ps
s'effondre il est derrière le vrai fait
nouveau c'est que le ps s'effondre comme
prévu d'ailleurs bon donc je recommande
quand même qu'on ne surévaluent pas en
permanence sous prétexte qu'il faut
faire vendre le front national dont
chacun peut constater aujourd'hui évalué
pour vous non les dans les commentaires
déjà une chose que les sondages ne
montrent pas ses taux d'abstention il
sera forcément très fort à gauche
comment voulez vous qu'un électeur de
gauche cette envie d'aller voter
aujourd'hui pour un candidat socialiste
qui va lui dire je soutiens françois
hollande tellement il est formidable
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure dernière
question sur le positionnement européen
on a envie de savoir puisque vous dites
l'oeil et oui l'année s'est bien engagé
une politique est redressée sur la
question européenne et des questions
n'est ce pas d'abord à vous avez des
chez vous des souverainistes des gens
qui sont un petit peu plus heureux 70e
il y en a mais le vrai sujet n'est pas
celui là le vrai sujet le suivant l'ump
est profondément européenne
je suis profondément européen mais mon
identité est française et en même temps
à l'intérieur de l'europe
nous commémorons le centenaire de 14-18
ont peut-être quelques-uns à rappeler à
nos concitoyens que l'europe dans
laquelle nous vivons aujourd'hui une
europe de paix en même temps j'aime
passionnément l'europe et donc je me
sens très libre pour dire que j'en veux
une autre que je veux profondément la
changer que je veux une europe efficace
une europe qui protège les citoyens une
europe qui protège
je ne marchais quand les marchés
américains se protègent ou les marchés
chinois se protège je veux une
harmonisation fiscale et sociale
bref je veux qu réécrivent schengen bref
il ya toute une série de sujets nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler sur
lequel je veux changer l'europe
mais ma grande différence et celle de
mes amis avec le front national c'est
que le front national veut sortir de
l'europe veut organiser le suicide du
pays
en sortant en revenant au franc français
qui ruinerait immédiatement des millions
de salariés et de retraités
quant au parti socialiste excusez moi
ils portent la responsabilité numéro 1
de l'affaiblissement de la france en
europe à travers son le comportement du
président public face à madame merkel
donc permettez moi de vous dire que sur
ces sujets nous avons effectivement eu
délit qui est très très offensive oui
nous aimons l'europe mais on en veut une
autre
merci d'avoir à aller troisième partie
de l'émission tout de suite avec perrine
tarneaud qui nous rejoint vous avez dit
que vous avez souffert de pour votre
image lors de cette guerre au sommet
pour l'ump
l'image de françois fillon a également
parlé un peu depuis
mounir souci pour la saison 2 de sa
présidence à l'ump jean françois copé
veut changer de rôle fini le costume de
méchants de service
après être passé pour la brute à l'issue
de son duel avec françois fillon
ils cherchent à se mettre dans les
habits du bon ses premières
interventions médiatiques du mois de
janvier étaient liées aux interventions
beaucoup plus douce beaucoup plus en
rondeur moins cassant - carey moins
directe et essayer surtout d'éviter les
critiques avec des camarades de parti
un pari raté ce week end il a échangé
des noms d'oiseaux avec henri guaino des
conflits qui brouille son image
résultat à droite même manuel valls est
plus populaire que lui
des sondages bas qui n'incite pas à
changer de ligne lui laissait pas de
deux de jouer un autre une autre musique
qui est plutôt celle justement de ces de
ses rivaux qui essaie de se positionner
pack de responsabilité c'est acceptable
dit jean pierre raffarin
on peut peut-être de faire un bout de
chemin 10 quelques cadres a donc lui par
contre il n'est pas du tout dans cette
voie là et quand ils attaquent la gauche
ils attaquent frontalement son opération
reconquête peine à convaincre installé
dans une opposition mécanique au
gouvernement le chef de l'ump a du mal à
se défaire de son personnage de francs
tireurs
mais at il vraiment le choix il fait le
job être président d'un parti
ça n'est pas facile tous les jours il ya
des difficultés tous les jours il faut
arbitrer et tous les jours il faut
porter le message qui est le nôtre
prochain test de popularité grandeur
nature dans les urnes lors des
municipales
un événement qui permettra de savoir si
l'ump son président peuvent revenir en
haut de la fiche
voilà jean françois copé michel bonsoir
jean françois copé vous aviez dit que
2013 c'était l'année de l'apaisement à
ce que 2014 sera l'année de la
reconquête pour lui je le crois je crois
vraiment je vous disais tout à l'heure
que la france de 2014 n'est plus celle
de 2012
il ya l'ump 2014 n'est plus non plus
celle de 2012 et les images que vous
montriez de ce conseil national en ont
été je crois là la démonstration la plus
belle qui soit une famille politique qui
s'est rassemblée sur les idées je dis
pas qui peut pas y avoir ici ou là des
querelles de personnes oui mais mais
elle considère que l'on peut le
reconnaître merci de bien vouloir au
moins vous le reconnaître ce n'est pas
dramatique
vous avez déjà baignade et il ya des
égos il ya des personnalités il ya des
histoires différentes
je cherche une chose et je voudrais
vraiment vous payez cela en tête et que
nos auditeurs le comprenne bien je ne
ferai pas de synthèse à l'eau tiède
entre les uns et les autres c'était la
technique de françois hollande quand il
était chef du ps
moi je n'aime pas ça une ligne politique
ça doit être une ligne audible
courageuse moi je ne peux pas pour des
idées depuis des années j'ai une grande
constance dans ses convictions pour la
france liberté économique autorités de
l'état égalité des chances et des droits
et des devoirs et ses idées que j'ai
exposé j'ai écrit dans le manifeste pour
une droite décomplexée c'est pour moi
très important vous êtes prêt quand même
à garder quelques inimitiés au sein de
l'ump mais personne n'a envie d'inimitié
mais je crois qu'il ya deux choses vous
avez des inimitiés personnelles qui
peuvent souvent relevé faut bien dire de
jalousie bon là il n'y a pas là rien à
faire après vous pouvez avoir non pas
des inimitiés mais des divergences mais
c'est très sain depuis quand on imagine
qu'un grand parti politique
trois cent vingt mille militants sept
premiers partis militants de france
zijp qu'on aligne tout le monde nous
avons rassemblé les famille gaulliste
donc je suis issu centristes libéraux
radicaux
enfin tous et tous ces genres d'une
histoire ce qui compte c'est ce qui nous
rassemble donc vous fait le job c'est ce
que disait jean claude gaudin dans le
dans le reportage convient de voir et
vous l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises
dans l'émission vous lui aussi les
lundis le fait de le dire que le combat
qu'ils mènent à marseille était héroïque
moi je pouvais bien sûr je censure
marseille justement avec la candidature
cette semaine depuis diouf est ce que
c'est un bon point pour jean claude
gaudin dans le sens où ça va plutôt dans
le sens de la division de la gauche à
marseille crois surtout que face à une
majorité sortante celle de jean claude
gaudin et tous ceux qui l'entourent qui
est un bilan remarquable dans de très
nombreux domaines à marseille vous avez
une gauche qui est profondément divisée
et qui essaie de se retrouver
ponctuellement empressé de se partager
les places mais qui profondément divisé
l'école des rhinites d'un côté mennucci
de l'autre puis voilà pape diouf qui
vient se mettre au milieu tout ça monte
qui à part un projet très puissant et je
voudrais puisque vous me posez la
question vous dire que je suis comme je
crois beaucoup de français scandalisé de
voir la manière dont les ministres
socialistes défilent à marseille
quand je vois les mauvaises polémique
ils ont cherché à nicolas sarkozy ont
d'autres temps j'espère qu'on va prendre
on va intégrer dans le compte de
campagne de monsieur mennucci les
déplacements à grands frais de tous ses
ministres puisqu'on parle des
municipales et qu'on parlait les
divisions à droite à paris nkm qui est
de plus en plus distancée dans les
sondages par sa rivale anne hidalgo
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas dans sa
campagne
est ce qu'elle est distancée dans les
sondages dans le 5e arrondissement où
florence berthou fait un score qui est
très encourageant à deux mois dès les
élections municipales
j'ajoute que les sondages soyez prudente
parce qu'en réalité ils ne mesurent pas
le taux d'abstention
personne ne sait que si les socialistes
vont aller vraiment voter pour soutenir
leurs remises et vocalisation la
nouvelle abstention de gauche l'a
manifestement pour les prochains
scrutins pied pas moi qui le dit c'est
se dire c'est unique de tous ceux qui se
disent bah tiens si les gens vont pas
voter à gauche il se passera quoi alors
la campagne de nathalie mais moi je
voudrais fait une campagne formidable
dans des cours dans un contexte
épouvantable monsieur delanoë madame
hidalgo ont totalement verrouillé leurs
systèmes arrondissement par
arrondissement
donc tous et une taxe est difficile
c'est vrai la droite avec les divisions
il lucide ans mais ça bien sûr tout le
monde est heureux
des dissidences mai mais en même temps
le jour de l'élection les électeurs ils
vont voter utile vous savez quel est le
sujet premier monsieur delanoë il a mis
paris par terre aujourd'hui paris est
complètement étouffé bon du point de vue
du rayonnement économique du rayonnement
culturel cette capitale mondiale n'a
plus de souffle
donc je souhaite de tout coeur que
nathalie kosciusko morizet puisse
insuffler avec la génération qui est la
sienne notre dynamique pour paris bien
sûr je souhaite pour les parisiens sur
europe 1 hier matin vous avez dit jean
françois copé que les médias en braille
le pas à manuel valls avec une aisance
qui devient franchement anti
démocratique qu'est ce que vous voulez
un exemple journalistes sont tous des
vendus n'ont fait que ce succès soit
vous faites du mal inutilement n'aura
coûté parler de l'audiar
antidémocratique
je n'aime pas parler de médias anti
démocratique j'ai dit que c'était un
positionnement qui pouvaient poser un
vrai quelques jours d'un exemple absorbé
tout de suite comprendre monsieur valls
fait une interview chez vos confrères du
jdd dimanche dernier longue interview
trois jours avant il a présenté il est
obligé des résultats catastrophiques en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine et de lutte contre la
délinquance des résultats dignes de ce
qu'avait fait monsieur vaillant 15 ans
avant il ne lui a pas été posé une seule
question sur ce sujet dans cette
interview tu fais pas ça troublant comme
vous le défendez bien cédé alba je ne
sais pas on va dire on va dire celui de
vos confrères qui n'a pas pensé à
valider et vous me dites ça parce que
vous pensez que nous quand on est
interrogé on est loin en permanence à
toutes les questions je veux juste vous
dire une chose le vélo la délinquance
étaient dix jours avant il me semble que
l'idée dé on avait parlé dans son
édition du dimanche précédent bientôt
des excusez-moi l'immigration ces deux
jours avant celle vendredi
c'était le vendredi d'ailleurs on a été
un certain nombre à même se demander si
mu manuel valls ne faisait pas monter
cette espèce de 2 da proches qui a
scandalisé tout le monde de comparaison
avec les années 30 qui était une honte
pour masquer pour masquer ses mauvais
résultats mais que celui qui
l'interrogent n'est pas la présence
d'esprit sûr je pas combien six ou sept
questions tant poser au moins une pour
dire ce que vous avez pas un problème
avec les résultats de votre politique ça
on dit quand même long sur le fait que
quant à ministre de l'intérieur à des
sondages élevé on n'ose pas le contester
or je prétends dans cette affaire le
sujet majeur c'est les restes sont les
résultats de ce gouvernement qui sont
dans tous les registres de l'action
publique des résultats catastrophiques
et ça c'est inacceptable
alors quand aux manifestations et la
manière dont manuel valls en a parlé je
le redis sur votre antenne il est
absolument scandaleux qu'il est osé
faire un parallèle avec les années 30
parce qu'on est là il parlait de la du
jour de colère mais d'accord il avait
compris que le dire il ya un aspect
compris monsieur grossiord qu'il a de
manière extrêmement méthodique créer les
conditions de présentation de la
manifestation d'avant-hier de dimanche
dernier qui était une manifestation pour
le coup pacifique et qui n'avait rien à
voir avec les délires extrémistes que
j'ai moi-même condamné de la semaine
d'abord et que le fait de vouloir les
amalgames et n'a qu'une seule la seul
objectif repris en boucle par tous les
ministres et par certains médias et
l'asse d'expliquer qu'il ya un complot
qui unirait la droite et l'extrême
droite
or je n'accepterai jamais ce procès
d'intention concernant la manifestation
jamais toléré la moindre alliance avec
l'extrême droite
contrairement à la gauche qui fait de
l'alliance avec l'extrême gauche l'alpha
et l'oméga de sa conquête concernant la
manifestation de dimanche dernier vous
avez rappelé votre constance il ya un
instant jean françois copé sur les
grands sujets économiques notamment
vous vous êtes engagés pour la laïcité
fortement pas régulièrement mais ça nous
gêne pas de voir dans la rue quand même
des rassemblements qui unissent une
droite chrétienne très conservatrice et
puis des musulmans rigoriste voir
intégristes bâclé moi je n'ai pas fait
le l'inventaire de ceux qui
manifestaient ou pas dimanche nous
entendu les témoignages
oui oui l'association verlin question
encore une fois je trouve qu'on fait un
peu trop parlé tel ou tel manifestant
c'est le charme des chaînes
d'information permanente on est un peu
dans dans une hyper actualité je
voudrais juste dire les choses suivantes
chacun sait oui enfin faut le faire de
manière scientifique alors pascal mais
il faut compter et personne ne compte on
se contente d'une image et puis ça
permet de prendre un angle et
malheureusement sur le même temps on n'a
pas de chance dans ce pays c'est
toujours comme ça mais je veux juste
vous dire une chose
mon combat contre le communautarisme
contre l'extrémisme contre l'intégrisme
est un combat constant
et celles et ceux qui veulent bien
suivre les engagements qui ont toujours
été les miens le savent c'est pour moi
la condition d'une laïcité positive dans
le pays c'est à dire la liberté pour
chacun d'exercer son culte à condition
qu'il respecte celui des autres qu'ils
respectent les lois de la république
je veux juste faire observer une chose
je suis frappé de voir comment des
millions de français quelle que soit
leur confession et quels que soient leur
intensité de pratiques qu'il soit très
religieux ou pas très religieux c'est
pas interdit d'être très religieux ça
fait aussi partie de la liberté
mais je suis frappé de voir comme tant
de françaises et de français sont
simplement choqué dans leur intimité par
les projets gouvernementaux comme s'il
est ce que vous allez désormais assez
d'entendre le gouvernement frappe est
peut être un peu dépassé peu par un
mouvement que vous ne maîtrisez pas
d'ailleurs vous n'aviez pas appelés à
rejoindre cette manie la manif je suis
pour tous deux là mais pourquoi vous me
dites s'est pas vu venir c'est que de
nous sa soeur et qu'on n'a pas vu venir
j'ai dit depuis toujours le dr huber et
comprenait parfaitement le message des
français qui manifestent qui sont
exaspérés et vous avez vu il n'y avait
pas de banderoles extrémistes y avait
juste des centaines de milliers de
français à paris à lyon qui en ont juste
assez content de voir un gouvernement
s'immiscer dans leur vie privée dans
leur vie intime et qui le disent
alors après on dit c'est pas appelé mais
je n'ai pas vocation est dans la rue à
chaque fois que des français conteste
françois hollande
moi je suis désolé je suis par ailleurs
omniprésent grâce à vous dans les médias
à l'assemblée jeudi comme mes amis du mp
combien je tout le mal que je peux
penser de tous ces projets socialistes
mais enfin après chacun organise sa
propre bien sûr opposition c'est normal
vous demandez toujours la démission de
michel sapin on l'a dit notre invité la
semaine prochaine il a déclaré 022
demandé ma démission c'est peut-être un
message à lui faire passer les
transmettre afin prochain je pense qu'il
ya tellement peu de ya tellement peu
d'humilité dans tout cela en fait je
sais pas je serai ministre du travail ne
serait engagée personnellement sur un
résultat je suis désavoué au delà de
tout par la politique que je conduis
l'honnêteté intellectuelle c'est d'en
tirer les conséquences
je sais s'ils passent leur temps à taper
sur leurs prédécesseurs il a bon dos
l'héritage ma faim maintenant ça fait
deux ans donc l'héritage ça va pas
pouvoir le faire encore très longtemps
jean françois copé merci merci avoir été
avec nous cette semaine merci père il
donc à la semaine prochaine avec le
ministre du travail
on poursuivra bien sûr ce dialogue à
distance merci à tous et donc à très
vite
le club des municipales c'est le rendez
vous dédié aux élections municipales au